what we're going to do in this video is
think about optimal decision making by
rational agents and it's just thinking
about how would a logical someone with a
lot of reasoning ability make optimal
decisions make the best decisions for
themselves well they would look at the
costs and benefits of a decision and
they would try to do the action that
maximizes the difference between
benefits and costs so they would want to
maximize benefits
benefits
minus costs and this is an important
idea because i think all of us would
like to be rational agents logical ra
agents making optimal decisions
now when we think about benefits and
costs benefits you might try to quantify
it somehow maybe in terms of dollars
what's the benefit of say going to a
movie or having some ice cream and costs
we tend to associate with the price the
cost of going to a movie say might be
ten dollars
those types of things are known as
explicit costs when there's an explicit
price associated with it but there's
also something known as implicit costs
and the most well-defined implicit cost
is the idea of an opportunity cost
and the opportunity cost in economic
terms is defined as
the cost of the next best alternative
so if i'm going to go to a movie there
might be the explicit cost of paying for
the movie but then there's the implicit
costs maybe if i'm going to a movie that
time i could have used for something
else maybe i could have earned money
somehow and so a rational actor would
consider both of those and then compare
them to the benefit of going to the
movie and if that's what maximizes the
difference between benefits and costs
well they might decide to do that
now to make this a little bit more
tangible let's look at that exact
example
so right over here we are told
suppose you have the choice between
going to a movie for three hours versus
working for three hours
movie tickets cost ten dollars
if you work you can earn thirty dollars
an hour mowing lawns twelve dollars an
hour working in an ice cream shop or ten
dollars an hour weeding your aunt's
garden
what is the opportunity cost of going to
a movie for three hours and what is the
total cost
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right well we just have to go back
to the definition the opportunity cost
is the cost of the next best alternative
so what is the next best alternative to
going to the movie
well i can make the most money if i am
mowing lawns
if i am mowing lawns
and so my opportunity cost is going to
be 30 an hour and if i'm going to a
movie that would have been three hours
that i would not have been able to mow
lawns and so my opportunity cost i'll
write oc i'm not talking about orange
county
the opportunity cost right over here is
going to be
dollars an hour times three hours so
thirty times three which is going to be
a ninety dollar ninety dollar
opportunity cost
now some of you might be saying well
what about the twelve dollars an hour
for an ice cream shop or ten dollars an
hour for weeding your aunt's garden
well those weren't the next best
alternative the next best alternative
was mowing the lawn some people might be
confused and say okay i'm going to add
all of these together per hour and
multiply by 3 but you're not going to be
able to do all three of these things
you're going to have to pick one of them
and we're assuming that maybe there
aren't any extra costs that are not you
know maybe you get extra tired from
mowing lawns versus working in an ice
cream shop but we're trying to simplify
things so let's not get overly
complicated right now so at a very face
level or at a at a high level the next
best alternative is making 30 an hour
mowing lawns so that would be the
opportunity cost now what would be the
total cost well the total cost would be
the sum of the
implicit cost which is opportunity cost
is an example of that plus the explicit
cost so the implicit cost we already
talked about that that is ninety dollars
that's the cost of not this the
opportunity cost of not mowing lawns and
then to that you're going to add the
explicit cost of just the price of the
movie ticket for ten dollars you get to
watch a movie for three hours
so there's a 10 explicit cost so the
total cost of going to the movie is 100
and so how would an optimal decision or
how would a rational agent use this
information to make an optimal decision
well they would want to compare that to
the benefit of going to a movie and so
if they could quantify that benefit
somehow and say oh yeah the benefit to
me of going to a movie is 200 and that
difference between 200 and 100 that's
the best difference that i can get out
of all of my choices between my benefits
and my costs well then i'm going to go
to that movie
so i will leave you there and in future
videos we'll dig a little bit deeper
into this